So we talked about the equations that defined expectation maximization,
and we stepped through an example with some actual data
in the sense that it was data points. They weren't
actual, measured data points. But what I'd like to talk
about now for a moment is some of the properties
of the EM algorithm more generally. So one of the
things that's good about it is that each time the
iteration of EM runs, the likelihood of the data is monotonically
non-decreasing, right? So it's not getting worse.
Generally it's finding higher and higher likelihoods
and it's kind of moving in a good direction that way. Unfortunately, even though
that's true, it is not the case that the algorithm has to converge. I
mean have you ever seen it not converge? I've never seen it not converge.
>> No, because usually there's some kind of step
that you take and you just, you make the
weight lower and lower. So yeah, or something like
that. You know, no, I've never seen it not converge.
>> So it
doesn't have to converge. I think you can
construct really strange examples that make it do
that. But on the other hand, so even
though it doesn't converge, it can't diverge, right?
It can't be that these numbers blow up
and become infinitely large because it really is
working in the space of probabilities. And it's,
it's pretty well behaved as far as that's concerned.
>> That's a difference between in k means, right? So, the argument for
k means, if I recall, which feels like was about a week ago,
when we talked about this. [LAUGH] But of course, it was, it was merely seconds
ago. Is that there is a finite number
of configurations and k means and since you
are never getting worse in our error metric. So long as you have some way
of breaking ties, eventually you have to stop.
And, so, that's how you got convergence, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, in EM, I guess the configurations are probabilities and I guess
there is an infinite number of those. Yet you can do more than guess.
>> So in fact,
there are an infinite number of those.
>> Exactly.
>> It wouldn't necessarily follow that you wouldn't converge
from that. But that alone is, is one big difference,
I guess, between the k means and the, the
EM. That's the trade off you get for being able
to put probabilities on things. So you've got an
infinite number of configurations. You never do worse but you're
always trying to move closer and closer. So, I guess
what could happen is you could keep moving closer every
single time, but because there's a infinite number of configurations,
the step by which you get better could keep getting smaller,
and so you never actually approach the final best configuration. I
suppose that's possible. But for all intents and purposes, it converges.
>> Right. Exactly. However, it can get stuck. And this
you see all the time. I almost never not see it
do this. Which is to say that, if there's multiple
ways of assigning things to clusters, it could find a way
that doesn't have very good likelihood but can't really improve
on very well. So there's a local optima problem that
is pretty common, and so what do we do when
we, get stuck in local optima with a randomized algorithm?
>> Cry.
>> No.
>> We take all of our toys home and randomly restart.
>> There we go.
>> Okay.
>> And the last thing to mention is this, is, is what you
just suggested a moment ago in the previous slide. Which is that, it's nothing,
there's nothing specific about Gaussians in here. It really is an
algorithm that can be applied anytime that we can work with
probability distribution. And so there's just a ton of different algorithms
that work in different scenarios
by defining different probability distributions, and
then all you have to do is figure out what the
E step and the M step are. How do you expectation
to work out the probability of the latent variables. And then,
how do you do maximization to use those latent variables to
estimate parameters? And usually it's the case
that it's the estimation that's expensive. It's
difficult because it involves probabilistic inference. Right?
So it's just like Bayes net stuff.
>> Mm.
>> And the maximization is often just,
you know, counting things. But it isn't,
in general, the case that it's always harder to do E than M. There's some
well-known examples where M is hard and E is actually quite easy. You know, for
any given problem you have some work to do to derive what the E and
the M steps are. But it's very general, it's a
really it's a good tool to have in your toolbox.
>> I like that. So, basically it's not that
hard because it's just a small matter of math programming.
>> Indeed.